bueno
cientos de personas se unieron para
rendir homenaje a samuel para ti en la
que llamaron una marcha blanca
el profesor fue decapitado por haber
mostrado unas caricaturas del profeta
mahoma a sus alumnos en una clase sobre
libertad de expresión un hecho que
provocó gran conmoción en toda francia y
sacudió a la ciudad de confianza antón
erin en las afueras de parís
el rol de los docentes es compartir esto
porque es un hecho visual y precisamente
debemos compartir estas caricaturas
debemos mostrárselas a los alumnos
que saben que existen y que tenemos
derecho a blasfemar en francia
tras el asesinato del pasado viernes el
dolor y la indignación se han
multiplicado al igual que los llamados
para ayudar y proteger mejor a los
profesores en francia- el presidente de
manuel macrón dijo que el país estaba
intensificando la lucha contra el
radicalismo islamista y todas las
acciones se debieron a la movilización
precisamente de esta lucha contra la
radicalización que también se
intensificó hace casi un año vimos un
declive territorial y sus comités
locales están en su forma actual
precisamente como lo hemos establecido
hoy con tangibles resultados estas
últimas semanas lo han demostrado aquí
en este departamento y son fundamentales
el gobierno francés rendirá homenaje a
samuel para ti en una ceremonia para
condecorarlo como caballero de la legión
de honor mientras que siete personas
están llamadas a declarar este miércoles
ante un juez por su presunta complicidad
con el asesinato del maestro entre ellas
hay dos menores de edad y el padre de
una alumna